Merci !
(Applaudissements)
Ce n'est pas nouveau.
On sait cela depuis longtemps mais --
(Rires)
Mais ceci est quatre tiers.
Faisons une autre expérience.
Prenons un son, ce son : (Bip)
C'est un « la » parfait, 440Hz.
Multiplions-le par deux.
On obtient ceci : (Bip).
Quand nous les jouons ensemble, on entend ceci.
C'est une octave.
Nous pouvons jouer, nous jouons un son, le même « la ».
Nous le multiplions par trois demis.
(Bip)
C'est une quinte juste.
Ils vont très bien ensemble.
Multiplions ce son par quatre tiers. (Bip)
Que se passe-t-il ?
On obtient ce son : (Bip).
C'est une quarte juste.
Si le premier était un « la », c'est un « ré ».
Voici ce qu'elles donnent ensemble : (Bips).
C'est le son de quatre tiers.
Ce que je fais, c'est changer de perspective.
Je vois un nombre selon une autre perspective.
Je peux aussi le faire avec des rythmes.
Je prends un rythme et je joue trois temps (Battements)
par période
et je peux jouer un autre son quatre fois durant cette même période.
(Cliquetis)
Cela semble ennuyeux mais écoutez-les ensemble.
(Battements et cliquetis)
(Rires)
Hey ! Donc.
Je peux même faire un peu de charleston.
(Tambours et cymbales)
Vous entendez ?
C'est le son de quatre tiers.
A nouveau, le voici en tant que rythme.
(Tambours et cloches)
Je peux continuer à jouer avec ce nombre.
Quatre tiers est un super nombre. J'adore quatre tiers !
(Rires)
Vraiment, c'est un nombre sous-estimé.
Si vous prenez une sphère et considérez son volume,
c'est quatre tiers du volume d'un cylindre particulier.
Donc quatre tiers est dans la sphère, c'est le volume de la sphère.
Pourquoi fais-je tout cela ?
Je veux parler de ce que cela signifie de comprendre quelque chose
et ce que l'on entend par comprendre quelque chose.
Voilà mon objectif.
Je pense que vous comprenez une chose,
si vous pouvez la voir selon différentes perspectives.
Considérons cette lettre. C'est un beau R.
Comment le savez-vous ?
Il s'avère que vous avez vu un certain nombre de R
et vous avez généralisé,
les avez rendus abstraits et trouvé un motif.
Vous savez donc que c'est un R.
Mon objectif ici est de dire quelque chose
sur le lien entre compréhension et changement de perspective.
Je suis professeur et conférencier,
je peux me servir de cela pour enseigner
car, quand je donne une autre histoire, une métaphore, une analogie à quelqu'un,
si je raconte une histoire d'un autre point de vue,
je permets la compréhension.
Je rends la compréhension possible
car vous devez généraliser ce que vous voyez et entendez
et cela sera plus facile pour vous si je vous donne une autre perspective.
Considérons un autre exemple simple.
C'est quatre et trois. Ce sont quatre triangles.
D'une façon, c'est aussi quatre tiers.
Regroupons-les.
Nous allons jouer à un jeu ; vous allez plier cela
en une structure tridimensionnelle.
J'adore cela.
C'est une pyramide à base carrée.
Prenons-en deux et regroupons-les.
Cela s'appelle un octaèdre.
C'est l'un des cinq solides platoniques.
Nous pouvons littéralement changer de perspective
car nous pouvons le faire tourner autour de tous les axes
et le voir selon différentes perspectives.
Je peux changer l'axe
et le voir d'un autre point de vue.
C'est la même chose mais cela semble un peu différent.
Je peux le faire encore une fois.
Chaque fois que je fais cela, quelque chose d'autre apparaît,
j'en apprends donc plus sur l'objet
quand je change de perspective.
Je peux utiliser cela comme outil pour créer de la compréhension.
Je peux prendre deux de ces formes, les rassembler ainsi
et voir ce qu'il se passe.
Cela ressemble un peu à l'octaèdre.
Observez si je le tourne un peu ainsi.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Si vous prenez deux de ces formes, les rassemblez et les faites tourner,
vous retrouvez votre octaèdre,
une belle structure.
Si vous étalez cela sur le sol,
voici l'octaèdre.
C'est la structure de graphe de l'octaèdre.
Et je peux continuer à faire cela.
Vous pouvez dessiner trois grands cercles autour de l'octaèdre,
vous faites tourner
et vous voyez que les trois grands cercles sont liés à l'octaèdre.
Si je prends une pompe à vélo et que je gonfle,
vous voyez que cela ressemble un peu à l'octaèdre.
Vous voyez ce que je fais ?
Je change de perspective à chaque fois.
Prenons du recul --
et c'est une métaphore, prendre du recul --
et regardons ce que nous faisons.
Je joue avec des métaphores.
Je joue avec des perspectives et des analogies.
Je raconte une histoire de différentes façons.
Je raconte des histoires.
Je crée un récit ; je crée plusieurs récits.
Je pense à toutes ces choses qui rendent la compréhension possible.
Je pense que cela est l'essence de la compréhension d'une chose.
Je le crois vraiment.
Ce truc de changer votre perspective --
c'est absolument fondamental pour les êtres humains.
Jouons avec la Terre.
Zoomons dans l'océan, observons l'océan.
Nous pouvons faire ce que nous voulons.
Nous pouvons prendre l'océan et le voir de très près.
Nous pouvons observer les vagues,
aller à la plage,
voir l'océan selon une autre perspective.
Chaque fois que nous faisons cela, nous en apprenons plus sur l'océan.
Si nous allons sur la côte, nous pouvons sentir l'océan,
entendre le bruit des vagues,
sentir le sel sur notre langue.
Ce sont des perspectives différentes.
Et voici la meilleure.
Nous pouvons aller dans l'eau,
voir l'eau de l'intérieur.
Et vous savez quoi ?
C'est absolument essentiel en mathématiques et en informatique.
Si vous pouvez voir une structure de l'intérieur,
vous en apprenez beaucoup à son sujet.
C'est l'essence d'une chose.
Quand nous faisons cela, en faisant ce voyage
dans l'océan,
nous utilisons notre imagination.
Je crois que c'est un niveau plus profond
et que c'est nécessaire pour changer de perspective.
Jouons à un jeu.
Imaginez que vous êtes assis là.
Imaginez que vous êtes là-haut et que vous êtes assis là.
Vous pouvez vous voir de l'extérieur.
C'est quelque chose d'étrange.
Vous changez votre perspective.
Vous utilisez votre imagination
et vous vous voyez de l'extérieur.
Cela requiert de l'imagination.
Les mathématiques et l'informatique sont les formes d'art les plus imaginatives.
Et ce truc de changement de perspective
devrait vous sembler familier
car vous le faites tous les jours.
Cela s'appelle l'empathie.
Quand je vois le monde selon votre perspective,
j'ai de l'empathie à votre égard.
Si je comprends vraiment
ce à quoi le monde ressemble de votre perspective,
je suis empathique.
Cela requiert de l'imagination.
Et c'est ainsi que l'on obtient de la compréhension.
C'est partout en mathématiques et c'est partout en informatique,
il y a une connexion profonde entre l'empathie et ces sciences.
Ma conclusion est la suivante :
comprendre quelque chose vraiment profondément
est en lien avec la capacité à changer votre perspective.
Voici mon conseil : essayez de changer de perspective.
Vous pouvez étudier les maths.
C'est une super façon d'entraîner votre cerveau.
Changer de perspective vous rend plus flexible,
cela vous ouvre à de nouvelles choses
et cela vous rend capable de comprendre des choses.
Et pour utiliser une autre métaphore :
ayez un esprit comme de l'eau.
C'est sympa.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)